The new year is bringing new anime that fans
across the world will love.
Are you ready for a series about historical
warlords in the bodies of modern pet dogs?
How about the story of a girl who realizes
she's the villain in a video game?
All this and more are in store for 2020.
Junji Ito is horror manga's undisputed king.
If anything from his vast library of work
can be considered his magnum opus, however,
it is Uzumaki: the slow, sordid chronicle
of one small town's descent into madness.
The story encompasses everything from cannibalistic
body horror to isolation-induced psychosis.
Ito's always had a gift for balancing absurdism
with horror, but Uzumaki takes it further
than ever before.
Uzumaki has been adapted before, most notably
as a series of video games and a 2000 live-action
movie.
Nothing, however, has managed to equal its
source material in sheer intensity, until
now.
In partnership with Adult Swim, Production
I.G. has produced a four-episode adaptation
that will air concurrently in Japan and the
United States.
Ito's densely-inked style is a massive challenge
to animate, but teaser trailers reveal uniquely
detailed visuals that should intrigue newbies
and seasoned fans alike.
Just make sure you watch this one with the
lights on.
It might have taken five years longer than
expected, but at last, the finale of the Rebuild
of Evangelion series has a premiere date.
These films have always been unique: Though
they're most widely known as a retelling of
the original Neon Genesis Evangelion anime
series, they've grown steadily different from
the source material with each installment.
Entirely new characters have taken center
stage, old characters have been woven into
the narrative far earlier than in the original
series, and a completely different ending
is promised to close out the series.
If the previous films are anything to go by,
3.0+1.0
will be an innovative presentation of everything
that makes Evangelion the anime touchstone
it is, from dazzling animation to a clear-eyed
look at trauma on the precipice of adulthood.
What little has been revealed of the film
promises a breathtaking example of why anime
matters, and why Evangelion won't be fading
into memory any time soon.
"It's the duty of the elite to protect the
ignorant masses."
Drifting Dragons follows the experiences of
the crew of a massive "draking" airship dedicated
to hunting dragons.
The anime looks like something of a cross
between Cowboy Bebop and Attack on Titan.
The crew, a ragtag bunch from all walks of
life, live from hunt to hunt, using all their
wits to conquer beasts hundreds of times their
size and ensure full bellies and coffers.
The anime's use of CG promises to retain the
lush detail of the manga while providing its
own spin on Drifting Dragon's cloud-dappled
world.
Early footage is positively sweeping.
By air or on land, Drifting Dragons looks
ready to impress with a whole new type of
dragon-slaying.
Isekai anime has dominated the scene for years
now with its tales of everyday people dropped
into fantasy worlds.
Sometimes they're reincarnated as low-level
slimes, sometimes they're allowed to bring
their smartphone, and sometimes they're simply
stranded.
One thing unites them all: making escapism
totally literal.
My Next Life as a Villainess follows this
formula... for the most part.
Upon sustaining a head injury, our heroine
realizes that she, Duchess Katarina Claes,
was once a high school girl obsessed with
the game Fortune Lover, in which she now resides.
Even more shockingly, she remembers that Katarina
is rival to the player character for the prince's
affections, and thus the bad guy.
Like most isekai, My Next Life is all about
the wonder and strangeness of a different
world, but this one is more obstacle course
than playground.
What ensues is a delightfully wry look at
a well-worn genre with as much humor as it
has heart.
Viewers are sure to fall in love with Katarina,
whose dogged determination to survive in a
world built to destroy her yields fascinating
plot twists and genuine emotion.
Fashion has long proved to be a fertile source
of subject matter for anime.
Samurai Flamenco follows the adventures of
a part-time model, Paradise Kiss takes a look
at the struggling beginnings of a career in
fashion design, and Kill la Kill imagines
clothing as control.
Smile Down the Runway is set to continue the
proud tradition of deeply fashionable anime
with its own DIY flair.
Chiyuki, born into a family already embedded
in the fashion industry, has dreamed of becoming
a model for years.
Unfortunately, adolescence only saw her grow
to 5'2" - far too short to walk the runway
at even the most obscure Fashion Week.
Then she discovers Ikuto, a shy classmate
who has a tremendous talent for fashion design
that he has no idea how to explore.
Together, they decide to take on the world
of fashion despite their handicaps, and manage
to find that what's held them back might actually
be assets in disguise.
Smile Down the Runway's whole-hearted love
of the arts promises to impress - especially
when explored through such dauntless, lovable
characters as Chiyuki and Ikuto.
They might be short, shy, and underfunded,
but as Coco Chanel once said, success is most
often achieved by those who don't know that
failure is inevitable.
What a long, strange trip it's been for Masamune
Shirow's landmark science fiction manga.
It's been adapted into multiple award-winning
anime series, influenced culture-conquering
art such as The Matrix, been made into a variety
of video games, and most recently, transformed
into a live-action feature.
2020 will see the premiere of yet another
Ghost in the Shell adaptation, this one subtitled
SAC_2045, and it promises to be another take
on the story that's well worth watching.
Uniquely, SAC_2045 will use CGI animation
of a style rarely employed in anime.
The trailer, released by Netflix in October,
reveals a look at the series that is as brief
as it is breathtaking: Major Kusanagi, rendered
in three dimensions, appreciating the quiet
of a desolate landscape.
SAC_2045 looks to be a groundbreaking blend
between an anime standby and new frontiers
in animation.
In other words, exactly what a story set on
the bleeding edge of progress should be.
Keep Your Hands Off Eizouken! consists of
three high school girls looking to make their
mark on the world of animation.
These aren't the doe-eyed maidens of K-On!,
however - the members of the Motion Pictures
Club are bona fide weirdos who like army surplus
equipment and obscure animation trivia.
Director Masaaki Yuasa, the visionary behind
Ping Pong and Devilman Crybaby, isn't just
the perfect choice to adapt the oddball manga
- he might just be the only person who could
truly do it justice.
Our heroes inhabit a world that shifts from
the mundane to the magical as they explore
their imaginations.
That sort of magical realism is precisely
what Yuasa excels at capturing, and likely
what drew him to the manga in the first place.
Like his previous work, Keep Your Hands Off
Eizouken! aims for the heights of what is
possible in animation, and will likely get
there in high, strange style.
Dorohedoro has been held in high esteem by
manga fans since its 2000 debut.
A post-apocalyptic saga of violence, magic,
and unlikely alliances, its hero is Caiman,
a man stripped of his memories and left with
a reptilian head after a run-in with a sorcerer.
His world is split in two: There's the Hole,
the derelict home of humanity, and there's
the world of the sorcerers.
Those of the latter camp visit the Hole to
practice their abilities on its vulnerable
denizens, Caiman being one of that unfortunate
number.
This cruel dichotomy is disrupted when Caiman
sets out to find the sorcerer who disfigured
him - and discovers newfound abilities that
will help even the odds between him and those
with magic at their disposal.
Quite a lot of 2000s anime aimed to capture
Dorohedoro's signature blend of horror, humor,
and fantasy - yet even within that field of
imitators, it has always stood out as singularly
confident, visionary, and gloriously strange.
Trailers and promotional spots reveal an anime
adaptation every inch as stunning and cheeky
as its source material, leaving fans with
only one unanswered question: How did it take
this long for Dorohedoro to get an anime of
its own in the first place?
Oda Nobunaga, a feudal lord of 16th-century
Japan, casts a long shadow over the nation's
history.
Regarded as one of Japan's great unifiers,
his reign was as marked by free trade, innovative
art, and advances in military strategy as
it was by brutal suppression of his opponents.
Unsurprisingly, his fictional portrayals number
in the hundreds: Nobunaga has appeared in
everything from Pokemon to the Sengoku Basara
video games.
Sometimes he's the villain, sometimes he's
the hero, and sometimes he's somewhere in
between, but over and over again, he is used
as an inspiration for storytelling.
Despite all this competition, Oda Cinnamon
Nobunaga will still manage to provide a new
twist on the tale... by portraying the legendary
lord as a dog.
In this anime, Nobunaga's death in the infamous
Honno-ji Incident was immediately followed
by his reincarnation as a modern-day shiba
inu named Cinnamon.
But Nobunaga isn't alone - it turns out that
a plethora of figures from Japan's Sengoku,
or "warring states" period, have been brought
back to life as pet dogs.
Legendary tactician Date Masamune is now a
French bulldog.
Fearsome commander Takeda Shingen is now a
Pomeranian.
Whether you're a longtime Japanese history
buff or a curious fan looking for something
new, Oda Shinamon Nobunaga looks to be an
anime unlike anything else on the air.
It's not every anime series that can release
a single piece of key visual art and inspire
ardent discussion, but anything made by Studio
Trigger tends to get that treatment.
Since its 2013 debut with Little Witch Academia,
Trigger has produced smash hit after smash
hit.
Its most recent work, the psychedelic action
fantasia Promare, managed to make $1 million
on only 30 screens in North America, prompting
a return to theaters that few anime films
have ever been granted in the English-speaking
market.
Enter Brand New Animal.
All fans have to slaver over is a single image:
what looks to be an anthropomorphic wolf in
a trench coat and a basketball-toting girl
with squirrel-like features, standing against
a neon-splashed backdrop of skyscrapers and
billboards.
If the upright cheetah in athleisure behind
them is any indication, theirs is a world
of humanoid animals like Zootopia or Beastars,
albeit one rendered according to Trigger's
highly saturated, ultra-modern aesthetic.
So far, those are the only details fans have
to pick apart - but Trigger has inspired the
confidence to make even those scant clues
enough to make Brand New Animal an anime to
watch.
There are series that take a while to find
their footing, and then there is anime like
The Promised Neverland.
Season 1 wastes no time stranding its fans
alongside its heroes in a truly disorienting
premise: a world ruled by demons, in which
oblivious children are raised as meat.
Emma, Ray, and Norman, whose lives have been
lived entirely within the confines of the
sun-dappled orphanage that is, in fact, a
farm, stumble upon this horrifying fact by
accident.
The first season sees their daring quest to
escape take shape and ultimately succeed,
climaxing in their first sunrise beyond the
walls of the orphanage in the season finale.
It was an immediate sensation, hooking fans
left and right with its potent blend of horror
and heart, all brought home by a kid's-eye
view.
The second season promises more of this, at
an even more startling level of intensity:
Though the kids have escaped their captors,
they have become completely alone.
What does the world beyond the walls even
look like, if demons who eat children command
such power within it?
Who of their number will survive it, and how?
What structures of power maintain the orphanage
system, and what will it take to rend it asunder?
Some of these questions might be answered
in season 2, some might not, but we'll all
be watching to find out.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.